okay so there's like a wacky almost
funny element to this story and then
there's a very real scary politically
substantive
element to this story
we're going to start with a video from
it's so hard to even say what this is i
believe that this is a christian church
okay
and
this is a rant at a christian church
about how the right the religious right
wants to take control of the educational
system
and use the educational system to
indoctrinate students with a
conservative right-wing reactionary
christian bible-based worldview as they
see it this is really scary now what's
the wacky part about it well
i can't tell whether this is a christian
church or an insane asylum there's
people screaming you'll notice that
while the guy on the microphone is
ranting
you'll hear other voices and if you're
watching you'll see people in the
background
talking over the guy
at one point it seems like the guy is
speaking in tongues i think although i'm
not an expert in speaking in tongues
and this is a movement where i can't
tell whether this is a church or an
insane asylum take a look at this now
lord according to your word we take
authority over our education system and
lord we call for righteousness in our
education system truth in our education
system justice in our education
i think the woman over the guy's right
shoulder just keeps saying
that's right that's right that's right
that's right i don't it seems almost
like this is a uh
it seems like the spirit has overtaken
them
we cast down that demonic hold of
indoctrination in our education system
so anyway now the guy's casting a spell
i guess to take control of schools and
god we declare that there's no education
outside of the word of the living god
there's no true education outside of the
renaissance the other oh well hold on i
almost talked over the tongues hold on a
second education outside of the remind
right
[Laughter]
so
extremely dangerous view about education
we want to take over education with
christianity
but also they're speaking in tongues and
screaming and it seems like everybody
should be medicated word of the living
god we declare according to your word
that all of our children shall be
disciples taught of the lord and great
shall be the peace and undisturbed
composure of our children so god we call
for righteousness in every level of
education i call forth righteousness
does anybody know why everybody's
talking over this guy in the background
it's a bizarre scene superintendents
righteous teachers righteous principles
righteous righteousness now and that by
righteousness and the word of
righteousness the demonic and the
deception and the evil that is taught in
the classroom would be driven up by the
hand of god driven out by the hand of
god driven out now by the hand of god
and god i thank you for young people who
are taught according to your word in
jesus name so
i i don't even really understand what
the hell is going on there
but
the really serious part is
they want to take over public education
and now for a slightly
just as just as wrong but less obviously
out of their mind view on this
we go to a clip of tony perkins tony
perkins the well-known homophobic
right-wing christian activist that we've
followed for for a long time on the show
he said well listen we want young
conservatives
to go into teaching
in public schools so that we can put our
christian world view into public schools
despite the fact that you're not that's
that's against the law they're supposed
to be separation of church and state
you're not supposed to be teaching
christianity
um uh
other than as a comparative religious
type class in public schools this is
their plan listen to tony perkins i
don't think we should abandon the public
schools i i encourage young people who
want to go into the teaching profession
to see the public schools as a mission
field we cannot abandon it we need to
run for the school board we need to be
teachers we need to be administrators
but we don't need to sacrifice our
children understand what he means by the
public schools are a mission field
he's talking about missionaries in the
same way that missionaries would go to
you know over the years they would go to
brazil
and make first contact in the amazon
and and try to bring convert people to
christianity he's saying see the public
schools as a mission field where we go
in and do the exact same thing
uh in that environment so i am not
saying we abandon the public schools we
too many kids are going to continue to
go there
but it shouldn't be our kids we should
send our our kids as teachers and
instructors right so that what tony
perkins is saying is and think about
this is dark ages stuff
this is
let's do the following here's the idea
our kids we send to christian private
schools where they get or we do
christian homeschooling which is
remember the overwhelming majority of
homeschooling in the u.s is is christian
oriented i think 75 close to 80 of it
their kids they do christian
homeschooling or christian private
schools but then they still infect the
public schools with their ideology
by taking the kids who went to the
christian private schools
having them go into teaching and then
send them into the public schools also
to teach christianity and to see it as a
mission field as they say to be
missionaries
in public schools which at least in
theory
are supposed to abide by separation of
church and state this is really scary
stuff so like listen i i get it
the guy speaking in tongues it's crazy
where we say medicate everyone
psych eval 72-hour hold but
they have money at least some
they're well organized relatively
speaking
and this is exactly
what they they're telling us what
they're planning to do and we know it's
what they're planning to do and when you
look at the level of organization i mean
look when the when the school mask and
vaccine stuff got going during covid
uh as the vaccines came out
um
that level of organization it was a lot
of these same people who were showing up
to the school board meetings they are
organized there's no doubt about it and
so if we don't take this threat
seriously
they may be far more successful than
maybe we're willing to admit